The
process of hard-boiling an egg involves denaturation.
During this process, the amino acid chains
found in the proteins in the egg are altered
from their original, raw egg state, with the
denaturation temperature varying somewhat
depending on the specific protein in question
(see chart here).
But in a nutshell, adding heat to these proteins
initially causes the proteins to partially
unfold or otherwise change their normal organized
spatial structure.
As this is happening, the proteins begin to
aggregate and coagulate together.
As heat continues to be applied, additional
bonds are formed in these clusters, creating
a relatively dense protein network, which
in turn results in the rubbery egg whites
and solidified yolk you find in hard-boiled
eggs.
As to why if heat is applied long enough,
you’ll get a greenish colorization around
the yolk, to begin with, the proteins in the
egg white contain sulfur.
That sulfur combines with hydrogen during
the denaturation process and produces hydrogen
sulfide, a toxic gas that produces an unmistakable
“rotten egg” smell.
Due to being heavier than oxygen and nitrogen,
which make up the vast majority of Earth’s
atmosphere, hydrogen sulfide can normally
be found collecting in spaces like wells and
caves, and it is not only poisonous but also
flammable, corrosive, and explosive.
Fortunately for egg lovers the world over,
the amount of hydrogen sulfide released in
the egg is so small that it does not pose
any health risk whatsoever.
When you cook an egg, heat is (obviously)
applied from the outside and works its way
in.
This is important to the topic at hand because
the solubility of the egg white decreases
as it heats up, forcing the hydrogen sulfide
inwards, towards the yolk.
Also notable to the topic at hand is the fact
that egg yolk contains iron, which is ultimately
set free from the phosvitin in the yolk via
heating the yolk sufficiently.
When these iron cations come in contact with
the hydrogen sulfide around the area where
the yolk meets the egg white, a resulting
chemical reaction produces iron sulfide.
Iron sulfide has a greenish, gray coloring,
hence the green/gray tinge around the yolk
of a hard-boiled egg.
The longer you cook the egg, the more iron
sulfide is produced and the more discoloration
you’ll see in the yolk.
You will also see a similar discoloration
happen when cooking eggs in an iron skillet
for the same reason.
Likewise, if you find that you still get this
greenish yolk ring in a hard-boiled egg even
when not overcooking it, it is likely the
case that the water you’re boiling the egg
in has a relatively high amount of iron in
it, resulting in iron sulfide being produced
more rapidly than you might otherwise see.
And if you’re wondering, aside from not
being terribly aesthetically pleasing, it
is perfectly safe to eat this green part of
the yolk.
Dr. Seuss wrote Green Eggs and Ham as a result
of a bet with his publisher, Bennett Cerf.
Cerf bet Seuss that he could not write a book
in fifty unique words or less.
The proper pronunciation of “Seuss” is
actually “Zoice” (rhymes with “voice”),
being a Bavarian name.
However, due to the fact that most Americans
pronounced it incorrectly as “Soose”,
Theodor Geisel ultimately gave in and stopped
correcting people over the pronunciation,
even quipping this was a good thing because
it is “advantageous for an author of children’s
books to be associated with—Mother Goose.”